قال رئيس شعبه الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه اهرون حليفه ان الامين العام
لحزب الله اللبناني حسن نصر الله قريب جدا
من ارتكاب خطا يقود الاوضاع المتدهوره في
المنطقه الى حرب كبيره حليفه اضاف في
مداخله بمؤتمر للدراسه الامنيه بمدينه
هرتيليا ان سماح الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
باستخدام اراضيه لاطلاق مسيرات باتجاه
اسرائيل يجعل احتمال نشوب هذه الحرب اكبر
مطالبا بلاده بان تستعد لذلك
لو خاصه نتحسن نصر الله بعد مرور 17 عاما
على الخطا الذي ارتكبه عام 2006 يريد
تغيير الموازين امام اسرائيل وهو قريب جدا
من ارتكاب خطا سيؤدي الى تدهور الاوضاع
بالمنطقه ووصولها لحرب كبرى واذا ما اضفنا
الى ذلك الثقه بالنفس التي ابداها الرئيس
الاسد في اللقاء مع ولي العهد السعودي
وسماحه باستخدام مسيرات ايرانيه من اراضي
سوريا كل هذا يجعل احتمال الحرب عاليا في
المنطقه وعلينا ان نكون مستعدين لذلك